well first congratulations girl
great it feels great um in this is the
most
unusual award show i've been to um but i
think everybody did such a great job and
really came together to celebrate music
and
you know it's that it's that thing where
everybody's just figuring out how to do
what we do in a different way you always
bring the glam
i'll bet it was fun getting getting
ready for the show and dressing up like
that
and then also you're you just made
history tying with thomas rhett
and you're the only female to win this
category three times
how does that feel um big night for sure
it feels great
um you know and there was obviously so
many uh
incredible nominees and performances and
winners
um so just to be a part of it i
definitely
just feel special where do you feel as a
ring leader for women in country music
we had such a push for women to get
better represented in this
genre on radio and even throughout
tonight's show i think that was
represented how do you
feel personally where we are at with
women in country music
well i mean you can't have too much of a
good thing so i would always love to see
to see more women
and more women represented and given
opportunities but you know we've been
taking
steps in the right direction for a while
now which is really nice to see
um and like tonight you know not only
having newer artists to neil towns and
mickey guyton get to
get on stage and do what they do but
also
you know me getting to honor some of the
women that
were all standing on their shoulders as
i said so
it's um it was just i think it was a
really great night for
for that for females in in country music
and i look forward to
more because again can't have too much
of a good thing can you talk about what
it was like to have
your son isaiah featured on your album
uh well first i want to say that i'm
a dummy for not mentioning my husband
or children in my acceptance speech
you would think after this many years
and seeing other people
do speeches and give some of my own i
would i would think of
people that are important to me um so
i'm sorry
but i i do love my children and my
husband
and um it was it was wonderful to have
isaiah
be a part of what i love um
you know having that moment i was like i
don't know how he's gonna do
i don't know he was super excited to be
there if nothing else he'll have like a
fun day
seeing what mommy does um so it was such
a
a great moment for me as a mom to have
him share something that i really
love to do and he ended up being really
great
in the studio which was just like i was
so proud
i just thought when i was watching the
segment tonight and you're honoring all
these amazing women
from the opry and all the ones like you
said that have gone before
i hear a lot of the younger artists that
are coming up like the new female
artists talk about you in those reverent
terms
and it seems like you have become you
know the loretta lynn to
these people who've watched you on
american idol and washington shows
how does that make you feel inside when
you know that you have affected people
the way these other people have affected
you
i mean i don't think i can ever look at
myself
like that um because those
i feel like a tourist still you know and
i'm i'm waiting for the day that
um i don't know i
i always say i'm waiting for people to
figure me out and and leave me behind or
something i don't know
but i i will never look at myself
the way any i or anybody else should
look at those
other women that i got to sing their
songs tonight
and as well as so many more so i don't
know it's kind of a tough question to
answer
i'm always really glad to hear when
people like what i do
so it's it's nice if um like i know i've
gotten to
talk to gabby barrett a bit uh because
we kind of
we came up the same way and um you know
i would love to
be able to give advice or anything any
way that i can
but yeah that's kind of a tough question
to answer